pero no
economía en france 24 saludo a mi
compañera daniela blandón daniela muy
buenas noches hubo martes de euforia en
los mercados bursátiles cuéntanos por ti
santiago muy buenas noches pues en la
bolsa de nueva york- ocurrió lo más
llamativo su principal indicador el
índice dow jones de industriales superó
por primera vez en la historia los 30
mil puntos pero esto qué quiere decir
santiago primero no es más que una
barrera psicológica aunque es cierto que
ya recuperó todo lo que había perdido en
la pandemia el dow jones es un grupo de
30 acciones de diferentes industrias
incluyen firmas tan valiosas como apple
y microsoft y otras tradicionales como
caterpillar y boeing pero no tiene otras
tan atractivas como amazon o facebook lo
que lo hace diferente de los demás es
que para este índice es más importante
el valor de una acción que el de una
compañía completa por ejemplo tiene más
impacto en movimiento que tenga united
hills al que tiene apple porque su
acción es más costosa también subió el
petróleo y hubo fiesta bursátil hoy en
europa
que cerró en su nivel más alto desde
febrero américa latina también se sumó
los analistas dicen que fue por el
optimismo por la vacuna contra el cob y
19 pero también por el aparente inicio
de la transición de poder en eeuu sin
embargo el presidente de donald trump se
adjudicó este resultado en una rueda de
prensa que también pudo haber marcado
récord santiago fue quizás la más rápida
de su mandato con una duración de un
poco más de un minuto escuchemos
tercerizados el nombre de teoría bc es
un número secreto 30 mil nadie creyó que
lo vería alguna vez es la novena vez
desde el comienzo de 2020 y la número 47
que hemos batido récords durante mi
administración y sólo quiero felicitar a
la gente de mi administración que
trabajó tan duro y sobre todo felicitar
a toda la gente de mi país porque no hay
nadie como ustedes muchas gracias
danielle hablemos de la tasa de
desempleo en méxico porque bajó durante
el mes de octubre si santiago en el
octavo mes del año se reincorporaron en
el d
o mes del año se reincorporaron 17
millones de personas a la población
económicamente activa pero todavía hay
30 millones de informales así lo anunció
la oficina de estadísticas la
desocupación venía de máximos en junio
llegó al 55 por ciento y desde entonces
ha venido bajando hoy está en 4,7 por
ciento el gobierno dice que ya se han
incorporado 10 millones de los 12
millones de mexicanos que salieron del
mercado laboral en abril problemas ahora
de argentinas ya avanza el proyecto para
gravar las grandes fortunas de ese país
suramericano
santiago al proyecto de origen
oficialista que crea un impuesto a la
riqueza le dio luz verde la comisión de
presupuesto y hacienda del senado
después de pasar por cámara de diputados
ahora quedó listo para ser examinado en
plenaria en los próximos días se trata
de un aporte extraordinario de aquellos
con una riqueza de más de 200 millones
de pesos argentinos o sea 25 millones de
dólares
con los recursos se pretende ayudar a
levantar al país de la crisis justo hoy
se conoció a propósito que el índice de
actividad económica que es un dato
previo al pib cayó 69 por ciento en
septiembre es negativo pero santiago -
peor que el abrupto desplome de meses
anteriores hablemos ahora de la
industria aeronáutica cada vez son
mayores las pérdidas de las aerolíneas a
lo largo del 2020 por supuesto por la
pandemia del cob en 19 sin santiago en
junio la asociación internacional del
transporte aéreo había pronosticado
pérdidas por 100.000 millones de dólares
para 2020 y 2021 la nueva proyección
apunta a que los números rojos irán
hasta los 157 mil millones 118 mil ese
año y el resto en 2021 eso se explica
por el número de pasajeros entre otras
cosas si el año pasado fueron 4500
millones a nivel global este año apenas
serán 1800 millones es decir menos de la
mitad
y la cifra del día para el cierre de la
sección son los 128 mil millones de
dólares en patrimonio a los que llegó
hoy el más quién es el dueño de tesla
justo hoy cuando la compañía de autos de
lujo pasó los 500 mil millones de
dólares en valor de mercado con esto más
que supera por unos pocos dólares a bill
gates y se convierte en la segunda
persona más rica del mundo según la
revista de millonarios de bloomberg sólo
hay una persona más rica que ellos 2
santiago 10 besos el dueño de amazon
muchas gracias por este dato daniela por
actualizar nos en el mundo de economía
es todo aquí en france 24 siga con
nuestra programación buenas noches
[Música]